what's the one thought that you have are
the one belief you hold that a large
majority of people would disagree with
you on yeah so there's a lot of things I
mean I the I I would already consider
myself a Bitcoin maximalist which i
think is a minority position but I think
it's probably more interesting to see
you know sort of even in the universe of
Bitcoin maximalism which oftentimes to
outsiders is this sort of amorphous blob
of a community right where everybody is
aligned and you know sort of eat steak
and you know hates socialists and is all
sort of the the same type of person and
loves guns and while I love guns and
hate socialists I'm actually a
vegetarian so there's a minority
position there but I think that my the
more interesting question is is kind of
what do I disagree with most even in the
sort of Bitcoin maximalism world and
there's two things so one is that I see
cred credit systems and the sort of
banking systems being built on top of
Bitcoin as being inevitable I think
people will do them and I think that
they have the potential to work for a
really long time right and so a lot of
you know a lot of the a lot of Bitcoin
users enthusiasts especially those that
were here from very early on disagree
with that premise right including most
recently it's parked up in a debate
between cypher dynamos who wrote the
Bitcoin standard and George salgan who
was an OG cypherpunk Hughes and the
original he was on the original
cyberpunk mailing list he's with I
believe the Cato Institute now around
free banking and Bitcoin and I actually
find Sagan's to be very I'm very
sympathetic towards that I think that
all these sort of unique banking
constructs I think will merge on top of
Bitcoin and credit systems on top of
Bitcoin or inevitable and that we should
kind of welcome it I don't know if it
will be sustainable or work forever
especially because there are a number of
structural limitations to how Bitcoin is
designed and and these are good right
there are limitations to what you know
non Bitcoin sort of Bank actors can do
but I find that
of Bitcoin to be not only inevitable but
you know pretty interesting and so
that's kind of one large thing that I
disagree with you know in those sort of
Bitcoin maximalist universe the second
sort of belief that I would have that is
probably contradictory to many people in
the Bitcoin maximalist universe is that
I really do believe that in especially
in the short to medium term which I
would describe as you know even
extending past to the next ten years I
think that Bitcoin will be win or take
most not winner take all and it will
slowly increase in dominance I think it
said you know roughly 55 to 60 percent
dominance right now and I anticipate
that that'll go up over time but I see
two things as as potentially being a few
things as being valuable to the market
that will sort of emerge over time I
think privacy is sort of systematically
undervalued I think everyone says they
talk they care about privacy but you
know I don't think that's reflected at
all in the relative value of projects
and teams working on privacy
relative to everything else especially
in the utility universe so that's one
thing I think is sort of systematically
undervalued I think some form of stable
coin I don't think any of the stable
coins that exists right now that I've
launched or really robust
but I think that over the next at least
over the next five years I think a lot
of them sort of you know by design will
be you know very hard to kill right and
then they won't die for a very long time
so I actually see them holding some sort
of appeal especially because I think
that the design of stable coins though a
lot of it is misguided kind of Keynesian
nonsense I think that is it's that
narrative is very appealing to a lot of
people I talk to on Wall Street who sort
of look at that and go wait you know
that kind of makes sense to me
I can see you know this sort of
algorithmic central bank model being
compelling so I think we'll see that as
well so into in terms of how the market
evolves the long term I am sympathetic
to view that if Bitcoin is this sort of
black hole I think in a short term
medium term that there are a lot of
things that'll hold value because of
what the market views as structural
limitations of Bitcoin
for now